this is a production of Cornell
University
okay folks let's get started I got Mike
all right all refreshed right stout a
little bit all right so after that
introduction I'm gonna try to paint a
picture around the physical biological
and chemical processes in soils disa
giving you that to the basic level of
understanding and I know for some of you
this is very familiar for others maybe
not but it's interesting to see how
someone presents the information right
so I'll start with the with the physical
processes in the soil so one one perhaps
most important process physical process
in soil is the ability of the soil to
retain water go to capillarity so the
soil is like a sponge and that allows
the soil to hold not only water but to
hold the solution that holds the
minerals right the phosphorus the
potassium and all that all the minerals
so and that's really that concept of
capillarity that you have particles and
that you have water that the soil
routines within the particle is really
what allows life on earth you know that
allows for the cycling of water between
the soil and the and the atmosphere okay
so here's a list of you know some
physical properties and processes that
are important I think you're probably
familiar with all of those so I kind of
emphasized this water storage and water
movement but you don't want too much
water because you also need to have air
exchange right so especially the oxygen
needs to go into the soil but you also
need to get rid of the carbon dioxide
that comes from from respiration
otherwise you get problems actually the
I'm not sure whether people know this
but the the the biosphere project in
Arizona where they built this big dome
and they tried to have a self-sustaining
unit and and that was basically ended up
being a failure and the reason was that
they had forgotten about soil
respiration they've forgotten that
there's a
the carbon dioxide it comes out of the
soil and so they had this control dome
and the carbon dioxide level started to
build up and build up and build up and
at some point in time the people that
were living there had to had to get out
so that was a little oversight but it
did show the importance of soils right
so they didn't get the way right yeah so
okay so so in general about 50 percent
of us of the typical soil is is mineral
matter its particles roughly okay it's
kind of interesting because when you
look at soil you think that you're
looking only at at the mineral part but
there's also water and air and organic
material right so it's not all minerals
but roughly 50% the organic material is
um you know depends Co it can be 2
percent can be 5 percent something like
that and then the air in the water is
the one that's very dynamic
right so if it rains you get more water
being held in the soil it may all even
become saturated hun percent water in
the pores and then subsequently the more
air comes in and so that's the very
dynamic component but you know it's good
to kind of keep in mind about 50 percent
its mineral particles so a probably most
defining property of the soil of course
is soil texture you're not familiar with
that right percent sense silt and clay
or maybe course fragments like rocks and
we classify the soils so we don't really
think of this as necessarily an
important component of soil health
because it's not a dynamic property the
texture doesn't really change but it
does set the kind of the foundation of
the of the health in terms of certain
things so it's for example I'm a kind of
a taller than average person right so
that gives me certain capabilities maybe
I'm a little bit better at playing
basketball and it also gives me say some
challenges like sitting on an airplane
you know and so you have you
certain natural capabilities that are
enhanced basically based on the genetics
right so if you think of the texture as
being an inherent genetic property if
it's a clay soil it's naturally much
better at retaining water than a sandy
soil but it's also naturally much worse
that's a transmitting water or
infiltrating water right so so there's
these things that are sort of inherently
predefined by the texture so we have to
pay attention to it for the texture
because it is sort of a defining
property that we have to interpret
everything else in relationship to all
right so if we measure say the organic
carbon content or organic matter content
over soil which soil holds more organic
matter the clay or the sand the clay
right because it could it creates these
bonds between the clay particles and the
organic matter so if you see in a soil
with an organic matter or say three
percent and it's a clay soil you say
yeah that's not so good it was a sandy
soil that's great right so you have to
interpret everything relative to do that
so which soil generally has better
aeration the sand or clay tend why is
that more large particle of pores right
which Searles MO has most
plant-available water sand or clay alone
yeah actually that is the correct answer
that is the correct answer
all right so so it's these these
typically these ideal soils tend to be
kind of in-between right that the sands
are one extreme they have a lot of large
pores a lot of aeration and the Clay's
have a lot of very small pores or a lot
of water retention but they don't have
the aeration and the water transmission
and these intermediate alums the silts
are the best and that's typically what
you find also in these confluence areas
that we talked about like the nile delta
and valley indo-gangetic plain in North
China Plain there all those intermediate
soils so as I mentioned
this capillarity is in is a key property
right so the the fact during Co heat
because of cohesive and adhesive forces
you have some water
being very tightly held around the
particles and then you have this ability
of the water to be held between
particles and therefore you know hold it
against gravity and so that's really
what then allows if you have say a
matrix of particles it allows the water
to be held between these particles and
how tightly it's being held is a
function of the size of the pores right
so I won't go into details so the in
this case it's a system a soil at a
particular water content you see that
the larger pores have some air in them
smaller pores are all filled with water
so that's good you're holding water so
it's available to the plants but you you
also need some of that air because it
needs to be able to breathe alright so
you need you need both so okay so a
quick demonstration so we like to do
this and I always use this slide because
how many of you know spongebob
right everybody so I yeah for it depends
a little bit on your age so I'm Way too
old for spongebob but my children were
in the high time of Bo spongebob when it
was on TV so I watched a lot of
Spongebob it's a cartoon by the way for
those of you were not familiar with them
it still is on TV probably yeah it's
really it's a funny show but you know so
I always put this slide up because and
every time you see spongebob on TV or
maybe every time you take a take a bath
and you have a sponge you will remember
this demonstration right so so we have
here too so I have water and two sponges
right so what's the difference between
these two sponges the color okay that's
a good one yeah one yeah that's what
else yeah so this is this as large
portion this has mostly small pores
right
and so these are good you probably what
I'm gonna do you probably understand
this is nothing new to you but they make
for good demonstrations to a more
general audience right so this one I say
is like ass and they still miss like a
compacted clay right there's two
extremes and so when you put a sponge in
and everybody knows this right you
filled with water and then of course the
sponge loses a lot of the water because
it moves out of the large pores right
but then it stops after a while right so
maybe you forgive it another ten seconds
or so it will basically stop losing
water so there's two forces involved
here one is grab the gravity force which
move wants to move the water out of the
sponge and then there's the retention
course is capillarity which wants to
hold on to the water right and so it's
the smaller pores that are better at
holding on to the water than the large
pores right so now this so this soil
it's really the sponge is that what we
call field capacity so this happens say
in the spring or after a major rainfall
event so it becomes very wet the water
moves through the soil out towards
groundwater or whatever and then holds
on to a certain amount of that water
right and so this water then becomes
available for the plants
now is it a good thing that the sponge
is losing water yeah
why is a good thing so there's air in
the inn yeah exactly right because you
need the air it's also good if you say
have an aquifer down there that you know
needs to be fed and you know you're
drawing the water or whatever so what
are some of the bad things about that no
you lose some of the water right and
something that might be in the water
Mike nitrate or a pesticide or something
like that right so that's why we see a
lot more problems with these kind of
sandy course soils with with leaching so
this is then I'm gonna do it again but
we have the the three forms of water
right so one is what what I call then
drainage water so this is what's rapidly
being lost due to gravity okay and so
this is basically not available to the
plants at all like I said it's a good
thing the air gets into the into the
soil but that's all good then we have
secondly we have what's called the plant
available water right so if a versus a
plant growing in the soil it will slowly
draw the water out of the soil so I'm
simulating that by basically squeezing
it out right so that's the plant
available water and today we'll talk
about how we measure that right and so
it's a sponge is there any water in the
left in the sponge yeah just a little
bit of water left in the sponge right so
we call that the unavailable water
because it's there's some water in the
sponge or in the soil but it's so
Telstra helped so tightly that the plans
can't access it right so that's
basically so that water this plant
available water that's the most in a way
most valuable for for growing crops now
here's my other sponge okay let me empty
these by the way
so this was my compacted clay sponge
right now watched a huge amount of water
that's gonna come out of this punch when
I hold that up
oops right so why is this yeah it's all
it's all tightly held water in small
pores right so is it good I mean there's
a lot available for plant growth but
there's no aeration so the roots are
very unhappy right there's no air in
into the soil so it's it becomes
anaerobic exactly anaerobic no air
exchange no carbon dioxide being lost
very bad for growing plants right so if
you have naturally poorly drained soil
or if you have a soil that has become
compacted like this one right you can
send around you know you see that that
clump is very low in organic matter
content it has no aggregates it only has
small pores so it will behave like this
one here okay so the ideal soil is sort
of the one that's between these two this
one is losing too much water
this one is retaining too much water you
kind of want something that's right in
in between okay so I mean it makes for a
nice little demo and I think maybe Joey
will talk about some other demos that
are useful in terms of educating farmers
or students whatever on these basic
processes right so holding retaining
water in the soil it's is really really
important process okay
any questions about that so remember
spongebob especially young people here
all right so here's basically what we
what I just tried to demonstrate if we
have a sandy soil like the first sponge
you have a lot of whoops gravitational
water I'm gonna do it this way lot of
water is being lost which is none no
longer available and then a little bit
of water is unavailable very tightly
helped and but this is the the water
that's most important okay but that's
for a sandy soil for a dense clay
the second sponge very little
gravitational water in our case
basically none more plant-available
water but also a lot of water that's
unavailable it's so tightly held in
small force it's not available so the
ideal situation is where you have
something in between so a good you know
loam soil is you know some gravitational
water so the air can get in right some
unavailable water okay tightly helped
but you have a lot of plant available
water right and so that's why those type
of soils are the most desirable if you
look at agricultural soils most of them
are loam silt loams silts you know the
vast majority of the good agricultural
land is that sometimes maybe allow me
scent or something like that but most of
them are these intermediate soils so
what you want then is in a soil is to
have some small pores for water
retention some very large pores that the
air can get in and exchange and then
some intermediate pores right so how do
you get that well by having aggregates
so instead of having individual
particles you have our aggregates of
particles and a typical aggregate
actually has a certain certain hierarchy
in it so here's one crumb an aggregate
crumb right maybe what you see here like
one of these maybe okay that's one crumb
and then if you were to take that apart
you'll find that it has is made up of
other smaller aggregates and those
smaller aggregates are made up of yet
smaller aggregates right but it gives
you then that nice range of pore sizes
large ones for the aeration and a motor
transmission small ones for the
retention and a lot of the biological
processes tend to happen in this
intermediate pores okay and so in a way
the aggregates forms that skeleton that
allows for all these processes to occur
the water air exchange in a biological
function so and one thing that I want
you to kind of think about so when you
look at soil right at the one that's
going around or whatever you see those
minerals and what you don't see is the
porsche between the minerals but the
pores are really where all the action is
right and so a nice analogy that I'd
like to use is a building I'd say let's
take this building and you have a
skeleton and we're in a room here right
the room is supported by this building
structure the skeleton the most
important and most interesting thing
that's happening in this room is not
that structure it's us we are the
biology in this room right we're
exchanging if we were in sauna we would
be eating each other by the way I don't
want to do that we're just eating the
food but you know we'd be fighting each
other and eating each other expressing
each other but it's the biology that's
really important so so think of it as
the soil the minerals is being house or
a building and at the interesting
processes the microbes the fungi duh
you know what other other animals I'll
talk about that the action is really
happening in the in the pores right and
when we when we develop soil and we till
it
we're basically destroying the structure
we're collapsing the structure right so
just imagine that the ceiling would be
coming down to here I'd be a lot less
happy if that were the case right and
most of you probably - all right so so
that's what happening when we till the
soil we lose the organic matter that's
important for creating these aggregates
and then the surface becomes more
compacted we often do more till it's
infiltration degrees we get erosion we
lose more than organic matter that's so
important for the aggregates and so we
basically have this overall decline and
then we refer to that sometimes there's
still it's addiction because the only
way to kind of overcome this collapse is
to kind of fluff it back up again but
you basically are in a vicious cycle
all right so tillage is very damaging
any questions let's talk a little bit
about Sorel strengthen and compaction so
you know we need these aggregates to
have a relatively loose soil or a low
bulk density because it facilitates all
these physical processes like
infiltration water transmission and when
we don't have that we lose that like
that clump that you see there we start
to have runoff so a lot of the areas
that were initially developed for
agriculture that were not in these
confluence areas that were you know
maybe pasture land that was that was
being put in crop production this is
what happened and once you have that
once you start to get denser soil harder
soil the plants don't grow as well
you get erosion and runoff and then it
makes it worse so a lot of land for
example in the Middle East was a became
abandoned after a few decades so you go
now to places like southern Europe Italy
or Greece or turkey or places like that
and the soils are very degraded right
because they they became very eroded and
and it was a huge problem ok this is
what it looks like from the top you can
imagine when you have crusts like that
that you know you don't get a lot of
vegetation you see plants are having a
hard time growing right and so so and
this then interacts with the potential
for erosion let me try to explain that
so when you have soil particles and the
soil is saturated with water
it's a soil soft or hard soft right so
if you have a very wet soil you can just
push your finger into it if that soil
dries out what happens it becomes much
harder right and sometimes when it
becomes extremely dry it becomes loose
right so if you go to the beach and you
stand right by the water's edge you can
wiggle your your your feet and your toes
and you can this really soft you step
back and then the soil becomes very hard
the beach very hard like
they tone a beach if you've ever been
there and then when you again you're
further back what is it what is that the
beats look like it's just loose sand
right so where do you see the soil
moving at the waters
the water moves us moves to send
particles right back and forth right and
that's basically this scenario which is
basically water erosion on the other
side other end of the beach the soil is
loose you're sitting there eating your
sandwich and then the wind blows you're
eating sand right so it's on these
extremes and when you have a lack of
aggregates it's on the extremes where
you have the problems that's where winds
too wet you get the wind the water
erosion winds right so this is
interaction between the weather and the
stat the status of the soil and if you
have good aggregates you really minimize
those impacts I'm gonna skip that one
and that one too all right maybe that
one too sorry because I'm looking at the
at the clock a little bit so another
component so we're looking at the
sponges and you know how much water does
bunch can hold and so we say okay that's
great it you know you have that plant
available water but is it really planned
available there's something else that's
that that's a factor in that and that's
the roots need to be able to access the
water right so you can have a sponge
like this or a soil like this and it has
water in it but if the roots can't grow
into it right they can't access it so
you need both a soil that can retain the
water you need to have a soil that
allows the roots to grow and again
what's the best way to do that for the
structure to be well aggregated okay
because if you have aggregates you have
large pores the roots can get into the
large pores they can push the aggregates
to the side and you get much better
routing and much better uptake right of
water and nutrients so if you have a
very compacted soil you see there's one
root that went into the soil it may be
found the zone of weakness but most of
the soil is basically the water and
nutrients are not accessed by the roots
right so it's there
but it's not of any use to the plant
just a little bit here
Vermont Detroit so this is what you want
right so you want a combination of good
water retention capacity which you'll
see how we measure that in lab and good
aggregation and what the roots can
access it you see how we measure that in
the lab as well okay
so here's an example of this very
compacted soil like the one that's going
around and no large pores the roots can
grow into it maybe when the soil is very
wet it's a little softer maybe a little
bit of growth but this is you know you
can see here healthy soil is he an
earthworm
you see holes there channels
you see casts and all that and the roots
will grow very well into that okay
so it's not only whether the soil can
hold the water but is it also accessible
to the plants okay so I want to move on
to the biological component any
questions about it yes there are
methodologies that are that sort of take
the best of both worlds and one that's
notable is because drip village where
you where you do only a little bit of
disturbance in right in the row where
the seed goes and the rest is
undisturbed it works well with row crop
systems so that's that's kind of the the
best compromise because you know one of
the challenges with you know if you've
in intensively tilled the soil for
decades it has become addicted to
tillage it became so compacted that each
time you need to fluff it back up and so
if you didn't go what we call cold
turkey into into no-till it's going to
be a disaster because the soil is so
compact
so strip till is away where you say okay
we're doing a little bit of tillage but
we didn't minimize the disturbance and
that seems to be a good way especially
for soils that are naturally challenging
for no-till for example in colder
climates more clay heavy textured soils
they have a lot more challenges both
density yes so in a way both density
you're correct is a measurement of the
aggregation right of how what what the
pore space is but absolutely correct
yeah yeah we'll talk about some of the
the way we measure it later and lob
density there's an interesting story
around that so yeah good point
all right so let's talk about the
biological component then okay so why is
the soil organic matter so important so
it's only a relatively small fraction
maybe two to five percent typically of
the soil but it's it's such an important
fraction because it basically sustains
the whole biological system so in the
book building soils for better crops did
you get it guys get a chance to look at
that I think it was a reading assignment
so we use three fractions basically of
the organic matter and the living the
dead and the very debt it's kind of a
funny way of expressing it but it
explains quite well what's really going
on so each of them are important right
and we'll try to explain that so the
living is what it says the living the
stuff that's alive right so all kinds of
organisms it's a it's a very rich I mean
soils are so rich in in biological
materials so bacteria fungi nematodes
earthworms might springtails moles etc
and plant roots plant which are also
alive and they're all in the soil and
and this is only a small part of it
and what are the roles well they
basically make nutrients available they
acquire nutrients they suppress diseases
to help aggregate the soils so they
basically make the soil a biologically
well-functioning system okay and it's a
just a very diverse group their roots
are so we would sorted the plant
component and they have a lot of
benefits so anytime you have a root in
the soil it has basically benefits right
it creates for space it pumps carbon
into the soil you know sometimes very
deep into the soil it exudes servers
that stimulate the food chain activity
so it basically feeds some a lot of
these organisms in the soil and maybe
even a little chemical so maybe help
suppress say weeds or other organisms so
roots are are basically a big source of
the carbon that goes into the soil and
this is an interesting how many of you
have seen this this picture all right
it's an interesting picture from the
land Institute
it shows you a perennial wheat grass
that is a prairie grass and it shows you
annual wheat right so and then it's you
know of during a year time period joke
so quarterly so September December March
June so you see here how deep the
rooting system is of the wheat grass
even though you don't see a lot above
ground it has a lot of carbon actually
below ground and there's a lot of
turnover of those foods as well so it it
just releases a lot of carbon organic
matter this is the annual wheat so was
planted in September so you don't
actually see any roots there and then
this is December have a few roots then
it goes to the winter yeah it grows some
more woods and then this is around
harvest time but you see that the
dramatic difference between an annual
grass which is wheat in this case and a
perennial grass so there's just a lot
more carbon and nutrients that are being
recycled
or cycled in in a perennial system and
that's why some of these soils naturally
we're so so healthy and so productive
and fertile okay so that's the living
part so it's it's these organisms
earthworms mites and all that as well as
plant roots being living so now we're
gonna look at the dead
so the dead organic matter the way you
need to look at it is is is as a food
source for all these life organisms
right so it may be fresh manure that may
be crop residue that's being decomposed
and especially the the recently dead
material so for us you know when you see
something like this this is you know for
many organisms this is its time it's
like you know we're gonna be eating some
great stuff now this is this is like a
juicy hamburger too many organisms in
the soil right this is a lot of carbon a
lot of nutrients to them that helps them
sustain right so this fresh organic
matter basically feeds the biology of
the soil so we call it the soil food web
so the ultimate source of the energy is
the Sun capture through photosynthesis
by plants it may go through an animal
may be eaten by say a buffalo or or or a
cow or whatever but it gets deposited
eat of the plants that I offer move
manure and then that feeds the whole
system where some organisms basically
decompose the organic matter say
bacteria involved but the protozoa eat
the bacteria they release some of the
nitrogen the nematodes may eat protozoa
I mean it's a jungle down there right I
mean but this basically sustains that
whole system and if you don't have
enough organic material going into the
system like I was explaining in my
previous lecture then you diminish all
the life in the soil that makes it less
viable good so that
so we did the living the dead and the
very dead is basically the sort of the
material that remains after
decomposition tends to be the lignin the
organic material that's very difficult
to decompose or char char II is also
very difficult to decompose it still is
very important because that's basically
adds to the ability of the soil to hold
on to water and nutrients so if you have
say especially with a sandy soil that
doesn't have any natural capacity to
hold water and nutrients but if you have
organic matter in the soil then it does
okay
it provides cation exchange capacity it
through chelation it can hold these
these nutrients it also holds to the
mineral interaction between mineral and
organic matter it's what allows the
soils to hold on to the organic matter
okay so if soil can hold on to a certain
amount of organic matter a clay soil
more than a sandy soil what clay sort of
whole tongue can hold on to more organic
better than a sandy soil because of the
org organum in ER Ilan's very important
topic these days because people talk
about carbon farming and taking carbon
out of the atmosphere into the soil so
that's that ability to sort of to do
that it's very important okay so that's
what this is I kind of got ahead of
myself
so these strong bonds between organic
matter and especially clay and fine silt
is really it's like the capillarity with
the water the ability to sell the hold
onto water and the ability of the soil
to hold onto carbon is really very
important in terms of the broader
ecosystem and services carbon is also
very well held within this very small
aggregates because it's basically
physically protected the organisms can't
get to it
right also very important that's why the
clays are much better at storing carbon
and then
recently been a lot of interest in char
because it's so stable in the soil so if
you char it and put it in soil it's kind
of stays around for several hundred
years not saying that that's the
solution - some people think it's a
solution to the carbon problem but it's
it's an interesting idea so the amounts
force depends on the balance of the
gains and the losses so the serval will
store what carbon but if you say till it
you lose a lot of carbon or if you have
erosion you lose a lot of carbon right
so ideally you have more carbon going
into the soil than you then it loses but
there's a limit it has a limited
capacity to store carbon the same way it
has a limited capacity to store water
okay most of our soils have a good
opportunity to store more carbon so
that's why there's an interesting Carbon
Farming and Joseph did some analysis
that I'll show you tomorrow ok quickly
I'm going to go through a number of
biological processes that are that are
important sort of just kind of touch up
touch upon them so one of them is is
residue breakdown and an incorporation
so we have this this dead organic matter
so it may be residues it may be manure
you know there's basically fresh organic
material roots and then all these a
number of these organisms are basically
going getting to work once you have some
of these organic matter being deposited
you get the shredders out there you get
the the barriers out there to bring it
in like earthworms you get the guys who
ingested earthworms do actually both
they actually ingest the organic
material and then it comes out as cast
through egestion they coat and and
inoculate aggregates they support all
kinds of enzymatic reactions that
basically allows for the decomposition
right so just
sure so here's a dung beetle for example
so the dung beetle loves done of manure
and a very important process you know so
so these are great little workers that
basically support these ecosystem
processes earthworms of course who was
the one who studied earthworms very
early on anybody remember that what
famous scientists Darwin Charles Darwin
at the end of his career even though he
was already so accomplished in his early
work he decided to study earthworms were
you fascinating so they're they're
basically great great organisms they
they make holes in the soil which is
very good they create these very stable
casts that are basically great
aggregates see here you see there it
helps mix the soil increases
infiltration and and help provide
channels for roots especially if the
soil is compacted so these are really
great you can have too many of them
that's the problem here in the Northeast
where the invasive species the night
crawlers are basically taking all the
leaf litter and crossing some problems
in the forest but in most cases they're
really great organisms these are some of
the organisms that do the shredding and
and the herbivore a and basically kind
of take this organic matter maybe leaves
it maybe dead plants and maybe nor
manure and they basically make it more
available for decomposition okay so also
great guys out there nematodes or little
worms one of the things they tend to
have a bad reputation because sometimes
they attack plants and then they cost
diseases but most limited nematodes are
basically good guys okay they're part of
this food web and and so they're they
have very important ecosystem services
there's a whole discipline you know
people who are specialists and nematodes
it's just a lot of variety so
basically the idea is and and you know
our early soil health were involved also
a colleague Georgia Bowie was a plant
pathologist in in the idea that if you
have a healthy soil with lots of healthy
organisms that it creates kind of
suppressive environment right it's kind
of like the natural system if you go to
a place like Kenya and you go to the
natural savanna area you know everybody
eats everybody else even but everybody
keeps everybody else in check - so you
know that there's no organism that
starts to dominate right and you need to
save in a soil if the soil is not
healthy and there's not a suppressive
biology a pathogen can really take over
right and you need to have other
organisms that keep that pathogen in
check it may be there but it needs to be
kept in check right and it's the same
like we have with humans in society we
kind of keep each other in there's a
certain amount of checks and balances
all right
so if somebody's biocontrol magnets
opium is a serious soil borne disease
but Trichoderma so Pythium is a is a
fungus Trichoderma is no mice Oh
something it's like a lot of fungus like
it's something different and and and
they can basically suppress the Pythium
and there's probably hundreds of other
examples of where one organism keeps the
other one in check and I'm not
admittedly not the ultimate expert in
that but it's a very what we do see is
that when we have healthy soils we just
have less outbreak of diseases so that
brings us to the disease triangle which
is a very important concept in in
pathology so one is you need to have the
pathogen present right so if you have
say Pythium as a saw born in a disease
you need to create also an environment
where this pathogen will thrive and so
with say Pythium it's having less
suppressive you know having less
of other organisms that basically
suppress it but also if the soil is very
wet and poorly drained it tends to
thrive right so if you have a degraded
soil it becomes very compacted like this
and it becomes wet and a disease
organism will do much better in that
okay so that yes I mean the same issue
applies to you yes I mean when we think
about passages in human pathogens in
soils it probably never really given
that a lot of thought but we do
introduce a lot of human pathogens in
soil as well right right yeah that's
correct and and so if you have a soil
environment that's not suppressive over
those human pathogens it would be the
same thing that's correct yeah yeah good
point I hadn't thought of that
so so it's the the presence of the
pathogen the environment that may be
created by the interaction of the soil
say aggregation and climate and then of
course the host you know are you growing
a crop that is susceptible to a pathogen
for example beans are susceptible to a
lot of pathogens and you'll you'll see
that later when we are in a lab but say
corn maybe not so susceptible to some of
these so that's really but the the idea
is you know you can manage what you grow
right and you can manage the environment
by say creating a very healthy soil and
that way you can also minus the pathogen
okay so good rotations maintaining good
soil structure maintaining a lot of
biological diversity allows you to
suppress these pathogens and in many
cases reduce the interventions spraying
pesticides or things like
okay so another important biological
process is basically making nutrients
available right so nutrients in the soil
primarily are in organic matter unless
you apply it as a fertilizer and then
these basically are being transformed
and then the nutrients are being made
available but it's nitrogen or
phosphorus or whatever and that process
is called mineralization but you can
also have a process that's called
immobilization where the nutrients are
being drawn into the organic matter okay
so that's another important process
biological night that's another one
absolutely absolutely yeah I think
that's in in another slide yeah
okay so functional redundancy so these
are important processes but having a
rich biological environment provides
that functional redundancy which makes
it more robust and resilient so
aggregation I already kind of talked
about that and another very important
biological process so if you don't have
a by a strong biological system you
don't have a good physical environment
either because you don't get the
aggregations either through the roots or
through the earthworms or organisms like
that plant growth of promotion it's a
fairly new area or basically for example
rise of bacteria that help promote plant
growth you know so the plants and the
other organisms in the soil weathers
bacteria or fungi or whatever they tend
to interact in a positive way certainly
in a healthy soil environment and also
tends to be very important for inducing
resistance to especially diseases and
then the other compose
is that when we have a better aggregated
soil we also protect the carbon much
better okay because the we allow the
carbon to get into the aggregates and
being protected there right and so if we
build healthier soils we find that we
can build up the carbon levels in the
soil and then we can protect that carbon
much better all right so here's just a
picture so some of the mycorrhizal fungi
hyphy the protection of the carbon in
the micro aggregates and things like
that okay all right so I'm not gonna
talk much about the chemical process in
the soil because that's most of you I
think are more familiar with that so
it's the availability of phosphorus
potassium the pH CEC thinks like that
what so nutrient deficiencies but also
acidity and alkalinity very important
you know flow pH is a real problem due
to high pH typically less but also
problem fight or toxicity where you may
have say high lead levels or cadmium
levels or something like that in the
soil especially in urban environments
are there you go human contaminants
salinity so DISA T so this you know so
this D creates a lot of problems with
very compacted soils and things like
that so what's maybe kind of ties the
chemical with the physical and
biological is that the the nutrients may
be in the soil but it's still they still
need to get from the soil to the plant
right it's the same with the water like
I said you the soil may hold water but
the roots that maybe need to be
accessing it so it's the same thing with
the chemistry so if you do a soil
analysis traditional soil analysis and
you measure the phosphorus potassium
content and the P eighths and all that
it may be in the soil but can it be
effectively used by the plants well for
that you need to have good
nation need to have roots grow and be
able to access those nutrients you need
to have diffusion and mass flow of of
solution from the soil with the
nutrients like I said the roots need to
be able to proliferate there needs to be
good transport of the nutrients into the
plant you maybe need to have some help
like for example mycorrhizae fungi help
with the acquisition of phosphorus in
the in the soil and make in the roots in
a way that make the roots more effective
so the point here is that yes we know
how to measure phosphorus potassium
magnesium and all that all right but
that's not the entire story it also
needs to be accessible to the plants
through these biological and physical
processes right so again it's not only
about the chemistry it's about all three
of those physics physics biology and
chemistry all right and there's my last
slide because I just want to I don't
know whether some of you work more in
urban environments or not but we tend to
focus on agricultural soils but urban
soils are also important for a couple of
reasons one is that most people live in
an urban environment and increasingly
salt
alright and Searles in urban
environments are also important right
when you see a tree maybe you know go
drive 10 miles out of town you see a
tree so that's nice tree right if you go
to the Upper East Side in New York you
see nice tree that's we is worth a lot
more than the tree that's you know in
Lansing you know near my house so the
the natural environment which includes
the soil is more valuable in urban
environments right because more people
get to enjoy it and you know we've had
we've had many many urban areas where
the environment basically has been
destroyed and a lot of people live in
really suboptimal environments and
there's a lot of injustice
and and and inequity around that but
these are some of the problems that you
see in urban soils I mean it look what
it looks like so very high bulk density
very dense soil no aggregation typically
very low organic matter very poor
structure a lot of times very high pH
why is that it's a lot of concrete in in
urban areas low water holding capacity
very hard soil no aggregate stability
the roots can grow it typical urban tree
lives in a terrible environment right
very compacted often you know very small
area so and then you know typically
microbial biomass an activity very
diminished not only maybe because of the
pH a lot of times there's contaminants
in the soil in urban areas so we really
need to you know when we think about
soil health we tend to have this natural
affinity towards agricultural soils may
be some natural soils but in the urban
environments even though there's much
less soil it's so important because of
the high populations okay and that was
my last slide I think we did okay didn't
weigh Joseph or you did I this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu